[Music]
at
metro continuing to investigate a deadly
crash at tropicana and torrey pines the
crash happened last night 21 year old
jalen thomas booked for allegedly
driving under the influence and then
fleeing the scene joe muller spoke to
people in that area about the crash he
is live there with what exactly they had
to say joe
well brian the coroner's office
identified the victim a 77-year-old
charles wade jr people who live in this
area say tropicana is one dangerous road
now take a look this is where this crash
happened you can still see the markings
on the road police say the victim in
this crash was crossing the road
illegally and just before we went live
we watched someone else cross right here
at this point now police have a message
for drivers you're involved in a crash
like this
authorities say the driver of a kia
cadenza was on tropicana when they
struck a 77-year-old man around seven
last night police say the man was not in
a crosswalk right after the crash police
say jaylen thomas left the scene only to
return 40 minutes later with his mother
according to the police report his
mother convinced him to go back he now
faces an extra charge for leaving in
addition to the dui charge it is so
important to stay on scene first and
foremost 25 percent of our pedestrian
collisions have occurred due to
pedestrian air and if you leave the
scene you are going to face criminal
charges regardless if it was your fault
or not
[Applause]
now back out here live the public
information officer also tells me this
marks the 107th traffic related fatality
in las vegas reporting live near torrey
pines and tropicana joe muller live
local now